rio um único take on me atrapalhar ou
links toca para as pessoas não andam tão
um dvd que está parece no canal é e
deus não tava sendo não tava sendo quem
tem e quem é então eu não to conseguindo
não sei quantas pessoas estão assistindo
não sei como que faz o mangal ti em
limpar e e agora conhecendo meu canal eu
não sei meu deus cadê
ai ai
num 11 cadê velho que fez ao vivo no
canal não estou conseguindo nem como que
faz pra fazer a não ser tentar resistir
eu não tô vendo me mandou me mandar o
link ou porque as pessoas vêem e eu e eu
não me vejo no meu canal
desculpa gente cantou me vendo ai ta ai
eh [ __ ]
hum
desculpem pessoas como eu faço pra
deixar isso ao vivo velho deus do céu
não posso mexer na minha própria livre
meu computador trava mike bosta pré e
espera espécie é isto é só um pouquinho
eu vou postar no facebook que tem no
rock
o pessoal vem assistir
espera aí inspirei prédio por onde
também foi lucas emanuel dória de
cardozo você começar a fazer vídeos
quando você começou a fazer vídeos
filmes e fazer vídeos faz uns dois anos
eu não contratavam demais e esse é meu 4
aí gente o rapidão quantos anos você tem
perguntou agora fudeu eu tenho um 18
anos está 18
então quero pedir a vocês que estamos
assistindo agora é você que está
assistindo agora que nem gostei porque é
muito melhor é estar divulgando um pouco
aqui abidal bilhão bilhão
hidalgo jael volta só responder às
perguntas aqui na live tá
não vou responder
vou comprar um bom vou comprar na água
que é agora também podem comprar um
carro muito melhor perder a bosta
cheguei na tela micaela disso só luan
windows são você é super lindo muito
engraçado mandou beijo pra mim juliana
marcel bem pra você
juliana commerce 3 chute pra ele ver
vamos ver que ver tenho 69 os
espectadores am
gente alguém comenta aqui como é que faz
para deixar as é como é que faz para
mostrar quantas pessoas também
assistindo aqui eu não sei como ele
coloca nunca fez um rebelde não sei como
um país que não se editar não sei não
sei nada não sei como é que faz
então eu quero saber como é que faz
quer saber como é que faz para poder
deixar para trás a exibições deixar
aparecer mas gostei eu não sei como é
que faço aqui ai deixa muito canal
oficial ms ou um ano e aí cara tudo bom
em que você se inspirou para fazer vídeo
e me inspirei no pc siqueira como todo
mundo que gosta de fazer o que gosta de
fazer vídeos no youtube e fala que até
vontade de fazer vídeos no youtube a ata
não não você queime talvez siqueira só
isso nada mais que isso
é vamos lá vamos lá vamos lá vamos lá
vamos lá
aperta alt f4 muito engraçado é o
pessoal do sul tem preconceito entoar tu
henrique sul do paraná
você tem preconceito com o pessoal aqui
do sul não não tenho preconceito com
nada
aliás eu acho que é a vida das pessoas é
muito melhor quando a gente deixa de
ficar com preconceito zinho com qualquer
coisa tá quer saber se estava vindo bem
como é que vocês estão ouvindo br
quero saber se vamos lá vamos lá vamos
lá está um pouco travado um pouco na
crédito você só tem 18 aninhos que fomos
lá gomes é um só desses oito anos eu fiz
ainda este ano em janeiro
mandam beijos câmera que projeta melo
não de não dá pra deixar gostei na li
nada parece ver como a sinto na pa am
meu deus do céu gente que não dá para
gostei na livre eu não sei como é que
faz para deixar isso aqui eu nunca fiz
melhor esse aqui mas o bom é que você
está assistindo todos os comentários de
vocês a próxima livre a gente combinar
cilada de um mês
vai ser bem mais legal tá bom
estamos ouvindo estamos ouvindo beleza
estamos ouvindo muito bem quando você
vai fazer outra paródia então joão pedro
então o pessoal porque estava demorando
a sair outro para o meu canal é tá
demorando a sair outra para o número
pana ao porque quando você usa a música
muito conhecida ela dá direitos autorais
então foi a direitos autorais não
possuía dinheiro então posso correr o
risco de botar uma música ela estourar
em um lugar não sentava com isso porque
é sério é então não dá pra pagar as
contas com sorriso de vocês é muito bom
ver que as pessoas gostaram é muito bom
ver as pessoas se inscrevem no meu canal
porque gosta nos vídeos mas eu preciso
as pontas eu preciso apagar as luzes
eu preciso pagar o meu celular precisa
pagar a minha câmera então isso tudo
demora mas agora eu sou parceiro no
youtube parceiros do youtube pela full
screen que é a frase que me fornece ela
eu posso usar conteúdos de outras
pessoas agora assim ela vá ela me
concede e aí então eu vou poder fazer
paródias de qualquer música agora então
vou fazer a próxima partida vai ser na
muito chocolate do now
você ainda vê os vídeos do ps se queira
o gabriel desceu e perguntou se eu vejo
assisto sempre eu gosto muito do ps se
queira lucas emanuel perguntou você tem
produção não eu não tenho para adoçar eu
faço tudo só é é é o faz tudo só em
ajuda é osvaldo quando ele vem pra cá
mas ela não mora muito longe então é
muito difícil me fez só um minuto é só o
une a oni xuxa mil b então você malha
malhava eu olhava não malho mais o
victor matheus perguntou o que você
sentiu quando viu que o voto aprovado
tava bancário eu senti uma sensação que
eu nunca pensei que fosse sentir na
minha vida qual é a sensação é a
sensação de você ser um famoso na
internet você é um famoso da internet
você não é um famoso pra a vida inteira
eu sou um cara que as pessoas vão
reconhecer vão querer se aproximar de
você depois vou deixar
mas como eu já tinha para dizer muito
vídeo no youtube
o pessoal e assistir o álbum foi
aprovado começou a assistir a outros
vídeos em uma grande parte assim não
muito mais uma grande parte desses dessa
pessoa dessas pessoas já assistiram
virão outros meus outros vídeos
o meu trabalho então se inscrever no
canal do estado o técnico natal que é
assim bem rápido em uma semana e
conseguiu 30 mil inscritos aí vão falar
com raquel mas é assim mesmo
lucas emanuel perguntou como eu já vi
uma pergunta básica
você é um exemplo de outubro nordestinho
sim sim eu pretendo terminar o ano com
100 e escrito e eu quero nordeste lá em
cima tá ligado não pra mostrar que é
melhor que ninguém max pra mostrar aqui
a gente é do nordeste também para dois
bons conteúdos do jornal da tarde
yang o júnior andrade pergunta quando
você ganha por vídeo
cara não dá pra ter uma idéia de quanto
você ganha porque é o seguinte por
exibições se ganha uma coisinha e por
cliques nas propagandas
você clica você você ganha alguma
infração não dá pra saber quanto que é
sei que é muito pouco e se você pensa em
ser um milionário ganhar dinheiro com o
youtube é bom separar e vender cremoso
denis base é quando você estourou e
deixou seus amigos de lado não não
deixei meus amigos de lado porque eu
nunca nunca nunca fui de ser uma pessoa
e 9
eu simplesmente ignorar aquelas pessoas
que não falavam comigo antes não
gostavam de me antes e depois começaram
a gostar de mim por causa que eu fiquei
famoso por favor não sou famoso um pouco
conhecido só aqui pelas bandas do
nordeste
então as pessoas que eram minhas amigas
eu sou amigo e acha que as que não eram
as pesquisa onde quisesse diz as que não
eram geovane tu acha que já dá um
autógrafo já deu um autógrafo silva é
você foi chamado para algum programa da
globo no programa da globo
eu não fui chamada pra um programa da
globo mas de 11 de março
a globo vai vir para teresina e eles vão
pagar minha
passagem vão pagando hotel vão parar
tudo pra mim para eu participar de um
quadro do globo educação no quadro não
de uma reportagem do globo educação que
vai falar sobre redes sociais e como eu
vim falar no facebook a idéia é envolver
me chamar porque em função do sucesso é
samira tocantins com quantos anos você
começou a fazer vida e comecei a fazer
vídeos no youtube com 15 anos bem
pequeno fazer um vídeo muito ruim era
bobo fala meu nome paulo victor
a lei manda o cheiro próprio cheiro por
frota
quero seu corpo nu frota
ana paula santiago onde você tira tanta
inspiração para fazer seus vídeos gente
a inspiração para fazer meus vídeos é a
minha vida a sério a minha vida é eu não
faço o roteiro está poder fazer meus
vídeos eu sento e fala mas tudo aquilo
que eu falei já foi premeditado por
exemplo a história dos patinhos que
estava acontecendo
é eu estava conversando com um tal
começar um celular e pedindo pra cantar
cantar normal
daí quando queria perguntar eu não
queria cantar e cantar a música dos 5
patins e aí foi que eu fui ver aquela
história que conta a história de cinco
patins é maab tal então foi que eu fiz é
o coco celular
e aí a nota é 5 patinhos macabro pronto
só isso não vou gravar eu leio aqui pra
não esquecer sabe é é eu tô gravando
sobre infância e tal que é que depois
que senna veio pelo lacen e opacos a e
aí eu desenvolvo toda aquela história de
um patinho entendeu então inspiração que
vem na vida mesmo sendo uma coisa
engraçada
por exemplo eu quis fazer um vídeo de no
dia mas azarenka que eu tive na minha
vida porque essa era tipo um dia que foi
muita gente foi muito azar e muita terra
arrasada
eu fui chamado a universidade nunca quis
fazer nesta área foi chamado para fazer
universidade é quando ocorreu o chamado
da universidade
correr correr pra [ __ ] para tirar um
tal de reserves pelo setor que serve pra
ser um exército sem pelo google e ea
irmã véia cabo zé e dão tanta coisa e aí
eu ia faltar tudo isso mas eu não fiz um
vídeo de mais mas nada minha vida mas
pretendo fazer isso ainda lembra manda
um salve rápido é que a gritar você tem
respondido instagram de nada
um beijo pra cá o anima possa ser fã da
música sem nome é tá eu vou ensinar a
tocar a música sem nome um vídeo meu
filho chegou eu vou fazer um vídeo santa
música e colocar um tempo pra vocês
acho que isso resolve muitas coisas hoje
você faz muitas sociedades onde você
mora a jamile carvalho onde eu moro não
porque assim necessidade é muito
pequenininha cidade tem não tem nem 30
mil habitantes
então muita gente me conhece mas só
amigo da pessoa então não considera um
fã sobre a família acho que a minha
amiga liga foi aquela pessoa que ser
mas não sinto dar é o cara faz vista é
na a e b caiu é vamos ver vamos e erick
wilson você pensou no que eu te falei
espero que a última mensagem deixei
falando aceitarem em coisa em troca eu
não li ainda essa mensagem porque meu
facebook tatá meio quebrado aqui é bom
espera só um pouco gente rapidão de
repente rápido
peraí peraí peraí peraí peraí você se
conhece é eric jonas você se considera
uma adolescente não 1
você se considera um adolescente normal
se é tão grande
eu acho que eu sou normal
gabriel b onde comanda louca galera
pernambuco o aluno é pernambuco
sou seu fã do nordeste também recife de
bp iniciado muito obrigado por você
assiste sérgio que estão muito que
agradecer vocês vocês eu achei que ia
cair muito mas foi o contrário disso
parece que depois que eu vá hackeado
cresci muito e rabugento
o canal está fazendo 16 mil inscritos
não tenha um mês não tem nem um mês
vocês são muito legais têm muito cuidado
rafa são gabriel para meu nome é muito
estranho muito samba a notícia de que
ele ficaria com alguma fã já fiquei
inclusive estabelecendo muito rápido
mano falou que para de goiás ana paula
alves um alô pra nóis lucas emanuel
perguntou você assistir os vídeos do
felipe neto sim assistir assisti aos
vídeos filipe neto gosto
vítor vieira braga mandou um abraço com
os mineirinhos a kiwis um abraço para os
mineirinhos aí pô
fabiana leal manda um beijo pra mim são
um bem de família dela
nós aqui em pernambuco te ama cada 157
carol e acho que é isso muitos não me
responde edson silva não sei que desce
muito rápido eu pergunto mandá-lo para a
baía falou mandá-lo para natal rn onde
uma loucura natal uma loba rsf mano
silva carneiro com isso em que série
você tá você quer fazer faculdade eu não
estou em nenhuma porque terminei o
ensino médio e fazer o curso de artes
visuais fiquem na 2ª chamada que me
chamaram
mas eu não entrei na universidade
simplesmente porque uma pessoa que se
declarou a favor da ascendente o negro
passou na minha frente por causa disso é
a dose um mês pra mim gabi ela saiu lhe
um beijo tabela saiu e mandou um beijo
aqui pra tá bom na serra e isso mandei o
mesmo tamanho na serra mas para
guarulhos
vamos ver vamos ver se é mais perguntas
que quer perguntar mas alguma coisa me
ainda mais alguma coisa a alguém que vai
ter mais alguma coisa a gente pega o
youtube está no topo das perguntas no
facebook não pára aí você gosta de games
não goste games e meio na hora porque é
tão lindo arremate a bola para a itália
sendo rápido qual elas ligadas internet
ou sei lá com a velocidade da minha é é
ruim é ruim
mano mesmo pra eu da vilã e valentim um
beijo pra dar grande a gente vamos de
gente é todo feito herói
cagão pega de interação direta apertando
mais o erick o irã apresentou seu curto
freddy mercury
não vou baixar aqui para ver mais
comentários
a natália albretch perguntou você se
inspirou em alguém para criar seu blog
eu me inspirei muita gente para criar
meu blog até eu me encontrar sabe que
tipo quando a gente começa a fazer um
blog a gente vê como aceitar as pessoas
não sabe falar a verdade é que gostava
de nada e aí a gente começa a imitar as
pessoas que a gente assiste eu assistia
a gasóleo
e aí vai até aí depois eu se tivesse
sequer como se fosse um ser humano pode
ser que se queira mas depois eu comecei
a fazer vez só fazer 20 a samsung e aí
comecei a fazer uns bem legais e meus
mesmo
normal estava muito queimado ó só ó v v
ã o de marau pescoço ó voltava de regata
como ficou ó explosão vermelho aqui ó
é tem muita gente assistindo agora vamos
ver quem quiser fazer perguntas fazendo
perguntas em 321 você pretende trabalhar
na globo como se vai trabalhar na globo
estes lane rocha você é tão fofo muito
obrigado design ana carolina oliveira
perguntou quando você tem
eu tenho um eu tenho 13 862 que segundo
tempo jael toba
não não
é vamos ver mais alguma coisa é você
curte fãs os funks legais eu gosto não
quer ver
na verdade mas há uma coisa muito besta
de negócios anual de funk a pessoa acha
que é melhor que alguém só porque ela
gosta de fãs
você tá muito enganado se você foi o
idiota e não gostar de funk você vai
continuar a ser um idiota só isso nada
mais que isso
se você for uma pessoa legal e gostar de
funk você vai continuar sendo a pessoa
legal entendeu bem o recado é o seguinte
é a música dançante é legal
eu gosto da música por exemplo o o oe só
água de coco pra mim tanto faz eu gosto
no calão e cada vez eu quero na barriga
pra mim eu quero mas eu gosto essa
música não sei lá no único
nela num evento na letra de bbb bbb
as perguntas será que espera que as
perguntas estão apaixonou
vamos ver se na sala game está fazendo
ali agora também não sei que é de lançar
o game mandela cada vez até na aí
espero que sua personagem só passado em
que espera esperei esperei esperei
esperei
vamos ver a de lançar o game é muito
gata não sei que essa menina não conheço
a eu sei eu sei você conhece aqui na av
conheça aqui mais uns tapa por nenhuma
aqui nada serve para nada
ele só aparece aqui mais as perguntas
que mandá-lo para natal a roupa natal
não e gabriel então que tipo de música
eu gosto acho qualquer música que tenha
além de legal denis mais quando você foi
hackeado personne é o que você pensou
ver se existe com certeza eu pensei em
desistir ou quase de disse
eu pensei se vêem na rua vou aproveitar
que o canal foi excluído e vou sair
dessa com onde o youtube e vou vender
cremosinn sacolé gangue e viver minha
vida a partir de que o que motivou a se
fazer isso e publicado no youtube na
verdade eu nunca
na verdade eu nunca é nunca pensei em
fazer nada desse tipo sabe é é a verdade
é que eu tinha muita vontade de fazer
vídeos fazer vídeos não de ser uma
pessoa famosa por que por que você acha
que harry potter eu fiquei muito eu
fiquei com muita raiva
então um novo ser tão famoso e então
repete e aí eu comecei a fazer um vídeo
no youtube
aí não tinha visualização tá
o primeiro vídeo assim mais bem visto
foi o das no piauí é assim desde isso
teve cinco exibições fiquei super que
ele é um pouco a gente não se esqueça de
clicar em gostei tá e gostei
gosto do canal chafurdar e o carbon
power pergunto eu gosto eu gostava muito
de chafurdar ia gostar lo é é você já
matou a moça matei esperar aqui mais
mais mais mais mais mais umas perguntas
e cheirar cola mandá-lo para a galera do
problema da malo é o dinei e cunha com
um é um cara que que trabalha no
programa abalou quem é de fortaleza sabe
quem abalos sabe que não é de nenhum
então um abraço em uma roupa toda a
galera do abalo que eu ganhei o prêmio
lado nenhum troféu de melhor a ouvir e
eu sou o fórum de quem manda tira
colocando o troféu uma loucura de recife
karla lima beijo pra você a gente comece
aqui com o convite que vocês mais
gostaram que eu quero ver qual vez mais
gostava antes comentou a itaú vôlei aqui
comentar de vocês disse ele mais gostava
hum
integrou a abr ansa ela trava animais é
o deus que contador boston a entrava
porque eu vejo a coisa vocês não veio
hum
i mandou pra mim qual é a ana paula
perguntou ana paula em tomar é mandou
pra mim com esse objetivo no futuro
podem trabalhar sem fazer vídeos no
youtube
não eu não pretendo trabalhar sempre
fazendo espírito porque cantou eu acabar
meu sabe um dia eu to be vai acabar se
pensa que vai vai vai acabar acabar em
outubro acaba tudo
a terra então quem vai acontecer eu vou
trabalhar e que quer fazer da minha vida
eu faço o blog está certo
então eu faço humor
então se pode ter certeza que se pode
ter certeza que se não der certo a
minuto be
eu vou subir nos palcos eu vou fazer
stand up eu ou você diante eu gosto de
fazer as pessoas as pessoas meu deus é o
que está a acontecer com meus gols o que
aos olhos significa pra você
o mateus 10 perguntou olha só dão grande
amigo meu se não o maior
eu já tive o carro em um time ajude
muita coisa a ela tem que aprender muita
coisa né ainda é muito novo
quem sabe ela só tem barba mas já só têm
até 12 anos só então você pretende fazer
uma área cheia que eu vou tentar fazer
um rancho de amanhã na minha antiga
escola mas tá difícil o diretor não quer
liberar ele acha que é muita para a
formação de pessoas rebolo ano e tal
aí emitir silva tio e nem respondeu
desculpa m é que tem muita gente não
consigo ver com isso você pode falar do
meu carro com média frutti
eu nunca vi o seu canal cara mas deve
ser muito bom por sinal tinha de dar
venta naoto kan a mim a ana paula
ferreti eu acho que é isso
ela tá parecendo pouco vai ser assim
agora é mano a louca maringá e falei pra
dar um alô pra marina tem algum conselho
pra dar pra quem está começando no canal
tem o primeiro conselho para quem está
começando no canal é primeiro conselho
assim na quinta começa no canal é grave
de frente para luís grave com a câmera
que tem um áudio bom som e imagem é tão
bom mas se você tiver o áudio bom já tá
bom tempo o que transmite um blog só vai
entender você falar então se você falar
no microfone e uma câmera ruim vai
gostar seu blog na noite em que a imagem
é melhor não chegava de noite e de dia
pela rede é muito boa e não falei de de
de carnaval da escola de de funk
a não ser que você tenha o peão a
opinião muito diferente de todo o mundo
que já falou sobre esses assuntos não
fale me porque o pessoal vai gostar só
com a sua vida você pode ser engraçado
sua vida vai ser bem legal você gosta de
onde direction não gosta do jardim falou
roça edição massa renato augusto valor
renato augusto
é já falei o herói do canal tá é
mandá-lo o ceará ou evitá lo para o
ceará mandou um beijo pra mim a gente
manda um beijo
gabriela israel ouro e paloma ferreira
meio a vocês que algum animal ou um
cachorro bote pra favela água de todo
animal dá eu gosto de todos os animais
em mais um evento muito 500 o eco aqui
ac sol sol humberto muito queimar vou
morrer e vamos ver que mais o som você
assiste por vem a isabella não assisti
super índico
sou muito amigo do gabriel do oeste
o de júnior céu é muito pessoal muito
gente boa muito legal inclusive tá é eu
falo com eles por celular a eu muito
legal
vamos ver vamos ver vamos ver o que você
acha sobre os suplentes suplementos para
quem pensa que o momento é bom a gente
lamenta é bom bom é aquele que quer
aplicar em mal e você aplica no ser
humano isso é boa é bom
o suplemento suplemento e gente que que
tem as identifiquem reabilitação tem que
tomar suplemento ao poder embora rápido
em tão boa
vamos ver mais e mais homens é mais você
canta muito bem agora fudeu muito
obrigado a dizer não me responde mandou
beijo pra mim eu estava sentada num
canal livre que você mais gosta de fazer
eu gosto de ficar conversando com as
pessoas antigamente saía muito na casa
meus amigos não sai tanto assim mas é
vamos ver vamos ver vamos ver uma outra
pernambucana no canal melhor para buscar
o topo dessa gente
você já respondeu marketing e pego 2010
um recorde
quando um beijo pra mim é onde quero e
juliano um beijo pra você quer julian
wilson
você disse que gostava de chafurdar e
não gosta mais o daniel silva por que
você não gosta mas não gosto mais se
afiguraria é porque porque o carlos
vieira é uma treta com os meus amigos
abby fase envolve também o tipo não é
total nas dois dos meus amigos mas mais
que bom
não é que eu não goste do caio oliveira
mas tipo oliveira nunca me respondeu
para se ter uma noção
não que eu seja para ser o o o cara que
gosta do nordeste não tem nada a ver com
isso o que acontece é as pessoas têm que
se ajudar
só tem que ajudar a crescer juntos e
quando a pessoa começa a se distanciar
as pessoas para tentar crescer só isso
pô não sei é os vídeos são muito bom e
eu gosto muito assistir os vídeos dele
eu gosto do vídeo de surpreende com os
vídeos mas confessou eu também não
conheço oliveira está pessoalmente nunca
vi ele é não conhece acha fundaria eu
acho muito engraçado eu tenho até vídeo
desde o computador
o edson ávila o clínico pessoal sou
muito fã da xuxa foi a área mas cara e
verem pessoa não é tão louca docs é uma
treta e quando não sei explicar direito
não quero também para ocupar essa
história não goste diz
mas é isso aí eu gosto dos vídeos que
agora eu nunca falei com um com ele
porque nunca me responde costa do canadá
camila o bis o marcelo marcelinho paulo
sindhosp do canadá camisa ocas e gosto
dela também eu também tenho o número
delas é lá anda basta que está muito bem
já pensei em ser cantor
sim já pensei se encantou
vamos ver mas gosta de andar de cavalo
não tem cavalo
na praça nelson de estado e daniel silva
eo abraço aos meus fãs da boca com muita
raça pura um abraço das fãs nos estados
unidos então tem de verdade você e como
tal nós oeiras e yuri soares não sei k
faz muito tempo que eu fui lá mas ela é
muito legal ao site você mais acessa no
entra em sites não é sócio tube é pura
lorota só voz é muito linda sou teu fã
caiu cutrim muito obrigado caio mandou
beijos para ilhéus bahia um beijo pra
ilhéus bahia é uma louca galera de
maceió aeroporto logan a curtir
eu curti um vídeo pequeno foi o carnaval
já ficou bêbado já fiquei bêbado uma vez
foi muito boa
nunca gostei de bebidas besteira fone ah
ah ah eu vou ficar vou ficar beijo que
eu quero empresa na mesa me canso de
dizer que sou [ __ ]
não não eu só quis saber como era o que
sabe como é né arrepende também está
quero mais é que tomar a frente vamos
ver mais o rato roeu a roupa do rei de
roma
eu sei lá tem um tempo room quem o povo
também o aplicativo sim só mandou pra
mim e ana rosa oi pra você cara só tem
fama no aluno possa estar o who's
winning eleven santana a você as letras
na época comandando as perguntas que já
respondia e por que demora um pouco pra
chegar
é muito bem pra mim é ahmad netto é
frágil lançou a cheguei para perguntar
como foi a primeira reação alegar câmbio
falar pra ela eu achei me eu me achei um
completo [ __ ] da fala na sua
implantação é aliás só ainda vamos
passar porque quem é você não ia querer
gravar um vídeo com minha mãe chata a
gente demora muito um vídeo de sete
minutos léo gago que os 25 minutos para
tirar sete por falar muita besteira e
passa muito tempo sem falar pensa que eu
vou falar sobre qual o melhor do
carnaval melhor canal do youtube pra
você
melhor para o tudo pra mim cara deixa eu
pensar melhor canal do twitter em casa
que tanto o canal bom eu acho que eu
pude 7 costa camila low cost no badoca e
eu gosto de um call e moura dessa letra
eu acho muita coisa a mirieli aguiar
perguntou o que te faz feliz
o que me faz feliz é quando eu fico de
bem comigo mesmo por exemplo dar um
exemplo pra você quando as coisas estão
indo bem
hoje eu fui que não a deixei lá na
escola
efe rafaela chega na escola
daí o direito não estava lá a diretora
não estava lá o pessoal foi gravar na
hora o ônibus que ia sair todo mundo
saiu tinha dado muita gente vai todo
mundo foi embora na hora eu fiquei muito
decepcionado muito decepcionado então eu
passei o dia inteiro ruim nem pelo
orgulho
não gostei então isso não me fez feliz
se tivesse do lar tivesse gravado
estarei muito feliz porque essa coisa
está andando bem então não deu mas eu
vou tentar amanhã de novo se eu
conseguir tudo bem se não conseguir feio
pra nós mas mesmo assim vai ser legal
é o linkedin e don don lourinha e
ninguém ninguém então dom thomas gostosa
lapada na rachada com você pede que
tinha uma parada na rachada e aí gostoso
lapada na rachada é é um primata já fui
criado assim muito ela me tiram lembro
como é quer colmatar configurar pequena
do canal shape neto bom muito bom pra
mim já santana vasconcelos 16 jogos e
como estou de molho e só saí têm poucas
mulheres a proteger o meu super
ventilador a área ficha do santos e meu
treino é legal prática ilegal
thiago silva e miranda curte algum canal
tipo porta dos fundos ou parafernalha
curto porta dos fundos e ladário
parafernalha gosto também do negócio
maior porta dos fundos
vamos ver no museu de los e samira
tocantins e não conseguir ler cresceu
muito rápido quando um pouquinho a gente
é muito ruim para trás em violão mail
ela não está aqui porque o cara aqui é o
cosplay minha mensagem por favor
ele me chama a mulher pera aí tá dodói
sair isso é isso é isso aí pra isso
tenho de bim
ninguém da honda ou não
clarinha e ninguém dá um dom
hoje vamos ver vamos ver vamos ver é só
alegria da mulherada e mostram físico
diz que não vai guardar meus poético e
se você é meu ídolo sean murray o
conteúdo obrigatório
vamos ver aqui o caviar uma loucura uma
pessoa a uma pessoa que tem mais choque
com seus vídeos na rodrigues muito
obrigado a caxias maranhão
muita gente e gente tem quanto tempo de
lívia que eu não sei como faz pra ele
espera só um pouco
peraí peraí peraí o dirigente tentará
ver o menino manoki pintar ao vivo aqui
vou tentar muito rafael quando você vem
aqui pra recife vai gravar com curtis
vai se talvez eu vá no próximo mês
aí pra recife não sei quando não sei que
data não sei ainda mas talvez eu vá eu
vou gravar cinco oscar assim
11 11
é isso aí quando eu saio vídeo alexei
nem sei se vai sair tá em que ver porque
eu vou nessas paes mandou pra mim foi
uma seqüência em que ver porque que o
que né então não é tonys netão um
provável que eu faço de tudo e só não
quer pessoas principalmente o pessoal é
menor de idade
então o pódio
vamos ver vamos ver chegando muito
atrasada aí olha que eu já saí com amor
faz hora já pagou a câmera wilson soares
não não terminei de pagar também foto to
700 reais eu acho que deixei a gente
acha que eu vou conseguir trazer aqui o
time do barradão a equipe entrará ao
vivo com a gente tem o zé que nos vão
fazer parte do manual do mundo do iberê
gosta sim adoro os vídeos dele cantando
a saudade de pimenta-do-reino maria
paula pediu vou cantar saudade quando
bate a saudade eu pego as cartas eu leio
e releio aspirou bem fundo perfume o seu
cheiro
a fotografia que você e deus e eu quando
bate a vontade
a adin eu fecho os meus olhos me vem o
seu rosto seu sorriso meigo a tua voz o
teu gosto como eu queria poder de abraçá
lo e tocá lá você inspira coisa e rosso
e noite eu te ea ele foi para a itália
getafe adote está a ouvir vem aí ó minha
gente
como é que eu vou lá no youtube não pode
porque nada no processo
aí ficou 20 bem aí tem que colocar a
abrir a sua aba do youtube para os
comentários a itu desativa o coisa um
ângulo é o o som do youtube ele só que
ele não atendeu e disse eu voltar pra
minha família também portugal eu me
deixa falar com ela aqui né eu vou ligar
para ela aqui por aí
e aí gente por aí que eu vou tentar
trazer aqui ela já tá o nelson josé
nitro adote para os íntimos
vamos tentar trazer para o milan ou o
kers para entrar na live com a gente
porque eu tá preta une
eu vou voltar pra ajeitar na ifa que eu
me levo ela vai botar ao povo vê aí tá
todo mundo
não digo que senão não dá o link do
android não estudar solta e todos estão
falando a ela
vou ligar para ela é mais fácil ela vai
estar pronto no verão vai ligar para ela
essa lei vai da gente tem 216 pessoas a
assistir na gente
eu vou andar por aí e vou ver segundo o
advogado o meu de novo colega para o
efeito ligá-los é gente espera eu já
começavam já começa a responder às
perguntas de vocês misericórdia está
crescendo muito e aí o e tatá casa agora
está ali com a gente
lave-os objeto é o une ao vivo no
youtube
a irmã dela entrar é tem aquele que
encontra no a gente tem conta no orkut
falo muito também o lucas
tudo naquele ano e meio isso ela tem ela
já entrou comigo
tony diz que já entrou com ela com ele
tá bom e vai daí não ele vai mandar o
link pra tu tá eu já mandei 3 veja da
mandou clique no link no país oi caiu na
chamada com como ai meu deus sabe né
cara já não é porque é
ano ainda não falou nada meus créditos
o xvii época totais aí ela tá lá em
fortaleza e ainda urbano não mais beber
e lê alencar você escreve
a gente tem n e divulgação da fraca ni
loi voltou agora no facebook
tá colocou que total houve voltar agora
posso agora voltou a cair num velho de
fechar a ação né não
e esse é o de que eliana e hoje é a
fechar são autores brito é dar o cray em
oi deverá fazer um rali chega ao nível
aqui né
eitá fechou a minha gente eu não gosto
da hora
lá era no céu
o povo está entrando agora voltei lá 34
vezes botei minha gente tem que falar
baixo não dá em cima vai falar mas grita
comigo
a água está quebrada que a de camila
entra aí é que tá assistindo para sombra
vai eu vou cantar
ae felipe deixa eu te falei dei o tasso
kfa windows ou não lhes porque você não
entrei na network o ps fala meu nome
lucas emanuel jazz em um network eu sou
da full screen os eu não sou o cara
entrou que não vai ao chão a muié sabe
que eu tô agora eu sou parceiro tudo é
tem alcançando assim a inédita o outro
por exemplo eu posso usar a música dos
outros eu posso fazer isso que não vou e
outubro um bloqueio mais nos vídeos
vendeu está sendo hoje mais fácil falar
que tu pode dividir causa o direito né
é isso né a é como se é ético faz isso
pra mim ela já está escolhendo nada
vamos ver aqui vamos ver aqui vou dizer
que estou tentando e muito rápido
minha mãe me adora sair vitimando um
beijo pra ela dona já que lindo
já quem mandou uma espada jaqueline um
beijo a dor daquele livro aquele libra e
iene no mercado já que a lpn menino tem
gente nova zelândia onde a nova eleita
no brasil
a equipe está com um pé não tá nem aí
com 2 o teste é não é sudeste
thiago passos do facebook mandou um
foguete ambos mil em suzano abaixo pagar
e na aems e lenda muito rápido não já o
milan
um homem de 80 anos era ator só acabando
e postar um texto caminho escreve no
texto para depois entrar até amanhã
escreveu um dos painéis do cambirela 3 a
1 em edson no índice um fala meu nome
rosa mohamed ezzati é o diabo é a
macumba isso aí só se fôr misericórdia
manda um salve me mandou um beijo para
fechar de paddock ana paula santiago um
beijo peixe eo o índice mandou beijo
para mim sou grande fã kiko reais
ana laura cardoso ana laura cardoso veio
pra você é de goiás gente está subindo
aqui e ali presença e poucos
espectadores que gostei assistindo ele
fechou ouvir falar original não sei
desde a originalidade
o índice subiu esta do auto da
compadecida quantas vezes assistiu usa
falar do filme ficaria legal o primeiro
live que eu assisto a mãe kochi
misericórdia lindos oita lo fechou o dia
em um hotel e amor à camisa quer camila
8 kant alouatta reprovada ao vivo
a ação vai lá pra cá foi é e oi é de
qual estado pessoas em pé na mão com um
pouco é recife né héber não conhece
todas essas bolhas o espião e não é que
eu queria saber se aí é quando é que vai
ter que gostar de e negócio de de
desencontro
cm
nem a gente eles não tô bem e eu tô aqui
tudo bem que também é tem que ir
gabriel tem que todo mundo tem que hoje
vai ser fechação show é aquilo que eu
sei quando vai sair de novo e de novo
vai sair daqui uns dias em que estou
falando é livre hoje teve o vídeo antes
de ontem já nem todo dia eu vou gravar e
tocar a fazenda estava gravando eu vou
gravar domingo que vem esse outro lá
numa comunidade
o vídeo aula é que vai ser fechação vou
gravar vai ser fechado matou a minha
família também acaba meu crédito ó
mas ele não está falando com ela
tô te falando em nome da menina menina
cabeça do dunga chamar o alívio só mora
aí eu há senão amanhã está mudando
cantar leque cantar aí vai cantar só que
ela não queria aquilo que vai tratar do
meu jeito dentro do cabo almi do cabo
não ali a chuva está na favela a pé para
a favela
alec leque leque leque mac mac geral
geraldo geral acumulada girando girando
girando alek wek telefónica black
girando girando girando pela tirania
a roupa suja olha a deus ele rodou
maneiro quero ver aí eu não sei não mas
não tapou direita tá aí como é que me
lembrar um passinho do volante quero ver
o pai lhe todo em santo passinho a gerar
se amarrar ele é muito maneiro qualquer
um pode dançar é a revelação aqui no rio
de janeiro
se você aprender para lembrar o tempo
inteiro em nas comunidades ii passeio já
estourou do sated tipo van e também vovô
ou preste atenção que já vai começar por
um passinho aí todo mundo como fui muito
humano beijo da bruna um beijo para
bruno entrou no g4 nome da bruna
um abraço forte e com o pessoal de maio
em betim é o matheus forte está falando
lá nos estados unidos
o meu roteiro misericórdia
o eca e sem a minha tem senha não aceita
camila joaquim é duplicar o vale 300
pessoas assistiram a gente eu disse eu
quero saber como é que faz para colocar
pontes ou as visualizações da penha em
aparecer com as pessoas aí eu nunca fiz
este negócio é a primeira vez que estou
fazendo isso eu não sei
chama o júnior selva do curso é eu não
sei se está aqui agora
eraí eu assisto o livro das pessoas
coisa mais linda do mundo tem até uns 15
afinal a florzinha negócio e eu vou
fazer é seco é desse jeito não tem nada
o que menino eu aceitar livros outro
tempo quantas pessoas assistindo ao vivo
tem quantos gostei tanto em é eu não
acho que a confederação já tentei
configurar aqui no youtube já tem que
configurar aquino hangout não consigo
uma pesquisada é costume faz do exame
eu nunca dei um abraço na próxima quinta
na etapa perdi aí e desce de vez o aiq
2011 a gente estava cego final paulista
oculista aids assim você só tá chegando
45 centímetros à frente de passar 45 cm
é que você tá se está enxergando
embaçado pouco miopia
vamos ver você no ano alô pra mim eu
desceu rápido demais
deixa eu estava muito rápido da empa eu
te amo samira tocantins
isso é muito bom pra mim a paixão não
sei que é gustavo alvim da copa o
cachorro vai olhar
vamos ver o roda roda o filme vamos
vender nenhum fez a prova do líder
olhe é isso aí eu tô vendo aqui é o roda
ó tá aí por que não eu tô me convenceu o
pt é isso aqui mandar um beijo pra mim
kelly giuliano herói quando l beijo
carlos é isso aí vamos ver
a aae falar o quê - mohamed amor
dinamarca ganhar não quer apostar meu
abraço etapa do pas o elenco
o índice thomson em itá button a eta não
ea misericórdia caruaru e também não
consigo ver exatamente o que manda o
cheiro da onu um cheiro da onu
agora ficou bom e eu caramelo
eu ia do maiorquino camaro amarelo olha
olha essa rua maria eduarda mando beijo
agora eu fiquei mole mole mole mole
agora eu fiquei mal mole
agora eu fiquei mal uma mole
agora eu pequei mole igual a gelatina eu
sou doador cassado de rapariga onde vai
passar por você nem aí pra ver meu vagão
que está armado o último tem muita gente
essa hora deixa a quadra meia noite aqui
trás destas pessoas assistindo seu o
fechou
ainda está cedo nininho mandou sabe
falar na média a senhora não salva
médias água e oito mandados também gosto
da minha mensagem errônea e foi o
verdadeiro espinhas e matar uma pessoa
os hormônios ninguém se tornasse juliana
manda um beijo já mandou o rapaz
ai meu pai do céu também emitiu e ai
camila menina
bom ela estava escrevendo negócio do
prego dos seus créditos promocionais da
copa a nova zelândia não sabia seu lindo
mandou um beijo pra mim a inovação
mundial e na oceania mandou me um beijo
a maria clara pedro maia
seu zoom gabriele salvatores a
misericórdia
você nunca quer me mandava
despacharam junho fechou manda um salve
misericórdia desceu muito isso no vídeo
você falou sua infância tem que falar da
adolescência sei que tem sua história
são mais engraçados da opel idéia
olha aí a doença é isso aí o guarda já
abrangeu em entrevista entrevistas em
que estágio está o wii foi saudável é o
cabelo é o neymar sabe por que eu tô a
câmera está ruim passar o som da voz é
fundamentada quem falou outro mas é um
link do youtube eo câmera parece da
calcinha
camila é que eu vou te mandar o link no
chat do facebook da copa
estamos reunindo badotti também é bom
chamar o ramon almeida
a moça está aí amor amor é recomendado
com o sem nexo na li e vi pedro henrique
rego está pedindo o colega vai de 1º a 3
goiás 2
meu colega pedro henrique diego aqui
hoje é o de projetos e não de teresina
que tem um canal chamado conselho nexus
one assistir bom e bonito
camila quem faca ainda mais feia
esperei deixa eu fazer a minha igreja
não é careta
a primeira etapa da obra é fazer somente
uma vez gente tirou frente dessa careta
das eleiã ã missa a água na boca
camila está no seu facebook pessoal no
grande mulher todo meu grande a época do
bate-papo distraiu o meia viu castro
existem 600 cedendo foi bom a rua boy
camila está no teu bate papo é esse de
amanhã vou fazer amanhã uma boa escola
atacama é paga para entrar no jogo
é o que não está bom mas é bom caminho a
tal ideia já te mandei gostei não
a milão bate papo do facebook
o menino que teve p
quando eu soube blog brasil eu vou
fechar a rua e vi o link do facebook
para tocar ao vivo
minha gente é agora fazer alguma coisa
cantar para cantar porque eu me cantar
eu vou fazer uma alexei peraí peraí
jantar música aqui uma pessoa só dança
depois voltou e se revolta vai estar
todo dança da primeira não ocorreu
porque se ela pudesse revolta
o primeiro vá tá bom eu vou começar e
depois que ela se recorda a executar a
música é meu amigo ficar cara a cara
para falar agora vai quebrar um osso
além do nordeste está noiva do nordeste
a galera assistir à frente e manda pra
gente e depois o melhor futebol david
alegre amanhã a mão tema na faculdade
vai deixá-la na faculdade à noite de
amanhã eu volto amanhã amor já boca a
boca é e frango
uma coisa é coisa do caju parada foi o
menino possa não ser ele pois três deles
porque eu fiz um certo
alexei
aí eles me contrataram por três meses
não posso mais fazer o check-in três
meses
hoje que feche cura miséria e que não
pode dançar aqui com a gente ele
divulgar eles não tinham então dança da
coisa se encerrará em xeque a graça né
roque o vento bate papo do facebook o
facebook não chegou nada quem não vai
ae
eu não tenho vontade
o enredo tanta música seu nome e manda
um beijo pra minha amiga é gabi tac bwq
amiga que não estou bem
a camila é só ficar respondendo pelo
youtube é tudo que está aí à solta ótimo
porque há estoque total vivo coloca tony
do paddock o menino voto aprovado então
vinha sob a idéia é marcar o gol e
marcar no chão da softwell dominou girou
e falou o som do youtube daí não só eu
não não tô só tirou a nota essa a ideia
é o fato novo é que esse fogo todo o
pago ele pro meu peru é pequena roseta
ficando fui série comédia lê lay off
para saber quantas pessoas tem que ver
na gente
agora num momento 271 chega a 300
o toc toc nenhum convênio tem aqui onde
eu tô porque quem está a mediana lá eu
sou eu então eu posso ver entendeu
exigentes e tenta agora aí coloco do
facebook o link desse no youtube mas
colocar o dunga sobre o craque não pode
é ser uma reserva ecológica da cidade
para o seu novo e dá a linha do tua
música como vai ser o povo é bom escutar
ler
tô eu vou e vou ler aqui um pouquinho só
porque não fomos bem colada vai abrir
que o be que abre essa baixaria que ele
estava lá e vi no youtube
fui à loucura
josé alberto wenzel fazer um chamado
ele achou graça negócio do defunto para
matéria urgente de funk e até agora
solteiro e namora com todo mundo
eitá amor todo mundo ou casar com todo
mundo sabe quem é você o que na sua vida
mulher oi
nós seremos felizes câmbio e lindo gente
bota contar nossa história no tom
pessoal vai contar
hamilton colocou o chelsea colocou no
colo quando o facebook doc que o pessoal
não sabe que o tac ainda não vai ter
show é um pouco da minha mulher foi a
bomba vai até o dia 4 de fevereiro vai
sair o clipe essa mulher sim aí só com a
voz não sempre a página da música é
admitir o que é mulher é o papo é vai
tomar eu sei que ele está me vendo
motocross papel nisso eu tocando pelo
youtube eu não sei quem é 98 e itajaí eu
falar um também conformada com provinda
do ó usou gritou e falam calor das
séries com akele 24 centímetros
a mulher que bate quando você bebe
mulher que pega os meninos na cef e do
prace fez o 1-1 brecht uma fechação vai
também é co autor do segundo e primeiro
colocados oro mon a cantá não tá
cantando a mesma que vai sair ou lugares
ou legalize aie estão aqui estão não
colocam ao rio só isso ao vivo no
youtube com a nba doc mundo vota é
provável que seja mandada olha ai junho
selva
ele vai entrar
marcelo victor andré vai pois gosta de
mandar o link pra ele em três já mandei
então ótimo se verá quem olhe a logo do
ensino que sorriu
alô alô graças a deus a campanha
completa aí o ter o líder brasil
estou aqui tá pra pedir e não dizer poxa
do bonfim do mundo todas as pessoas eu
que todo meu coração tá na frente diante
de deus com vocês também entendeu
pedro bial que só pela televisão na
elite começa o vídeo assim hoje que fará
uma coisa pra vocês
minha gente vamos melhorar hoje eu fui
comprar sorvete
a mãe demorou bota nos 11 e teve gente
não acredita que o brasil vai sediar
copos de pettah desing peter eu não
admito eu não admito mulher demorar pra
botar meu sonho verde não olha só você
você você você que tá aqui agora nesse
momento você está me assistindo
pelo amor de deus manda canta padrinho
uma gente pelo amor de deus mandar carta
para dilma é preciso eu preciso como um
sorvete me olha olha olha olha olha olha
só não pode bater tóquio fechou o pregão
pela aqmi iso estupendo deixe ele pms
vice campeão agora camila emita camila
para mim é um colega meu ricardo araújo
colégio e pick ups
então qual é o meio é irmão da era hoje
ele te amo muito camila eu falei com a
irmã e pelo telefone ele ficava falando
ou deixando o nome do laço na área
também é bonito
o caminho é esse homem é tudo na minha
vida era o corpo dela no banhada a óleo
ele te quer cambando eu falei quando foi
para fortaleza melhor pra ele disse que
a idéia da entrega na minha cara
ricardo araújo ricardo halla hoje
passado ricardo araújo o efeito da apel
ea inovação
é isso mesmo produção
eu conheço aos em sinhá fora fato de
marina ter feito ontem não tinha a fama
eu peguei só rafah
o treino fraco de farinha começou cinco
farinha coca-cola ótimo perfil
eu não posso cantar não precisam talita
da criança eu amo esse marionete medinho
ficar bem tudo eu não sabe da maior você
não sabe da maior via quatro começando
um novo projeto o projeto maddock
gostoso com alegria
button que foi o campeão mundial
feminino
eu também eu estava assistindo o vídeo
daquela ano de césaro ela que é negócio
top
aí só que o meu senhor que eu já era
academia e eu fiquei muito magro porque
eu parei de ir à academia está viajando
muito
aí é eu voltar à academia de novo pra
ficar gostoso de novo aí o projeto vai
ser muito gostoso tá bom tá tudo em dois
mesmo em quase todo mundo venha não vai
entrar e se outra chegou o bom humor fat
que não existe um líder melhor que essa
o nordeste em peso aqui gente só falta o
atendimento agora funciona
johny coloca o teu é hétero microfone da
desabilitada não tá saindo som
agora o leão
o papa voltou e herói do céu ea noite
essa é a live mais animada do nordeste
ei câmera o que me toque
só que aqui técnica e beijar a bola está
agora o que acontece é só pegar bom a e
colocada na boca
meu deus do céu e morreu e sua luta
selva presença para o pessoal que está
assistindo agora
boa noite pessoal lindeman a afonso
júnior selva do curso é que está
começando mais um ano aqui tá faltando
gordinho do pudim é verdade daqui a
pouco eu acho que ele chega por aí né
deixa eu ver que mais quero é que está a
salvo andar e marcando presença aqui na
nossa livre também está comentando com
eles o mando beijo na minha amiga é gabi
a jéssica melo o beijo amiga cabe a você
e toda sua família e seu pai sua mãe já
tinha
a equipe do papagaio é isso aí vamos ver
aqui é é selva o em pé no link do
youtube já está no youtube assistir nos
comentários
o zytek de provar que o papa do do hung
up não conhecem há muito a se fazer um
piauí com a lei só um minuto e roy tem o
link do youtube e advogará entra no meu
canal no youtube que falar os livro que
é o link que foi apanhado por isso aí
fala que tá o feminino do doc e me
mandou matar aprovado o próprio eleitor
vai ver um vídeo vai vai
o exemplo eu vou ensinar a vocês como
saber se a água está boa ou ruim você
pega um copo de água e você pega um copo
de água copo de água e vai encarar o que
é isso em campinas mas é [ __ ] mesmo duas
vez estava procurando para me fazer o
negócio de ti para clarear os dentes né
a itália em casa vai deixar isso é uma
para eliminar a não mulher aqui tô
compartilhar o link agora as mensagens o
incenso e manda um beijo que eu dou fez
um l acredito em deus e julho a oi é
verdade vôo o som do youtube mostrou que
tocou no youtube aberta não se tiver de
casas abrigo também virou uma das drogas
é mais a pcr
assim disse bulhões
só acredita que naquela ligação gás 37
reais com o game sai lá
eddie e de 80 chegou acabou que o
treinador essa daí a falar agora há
pouco a moeda mas também ketnath uso só
que eu vou sair de casa
e essa tarefa está aí
eita joão de chamar joão pimenta está
por aí
peraí vou falar com ele comentou que
sair e gente pelo amor de deus vamos
todo mundo bota no facebook novo de
citar todos os maiores lojas e nordeste
aqui porque porque pra prontamente dos
nossos canais só esse pouquinho de que
350 pessoas assistindo tem que ser mais
vamos hop de novo
coloquei botei todos os maiores e
melhores canais mandam tomadas já o
iberostar atual campeão você pode dar
demonstração do respeito do seu respeito
como estão bolívia exportar primeiro que
mostra se mostra bem linda menina
nato não gostasse não vídeo mostra o
peito mesmo na mostra com a camisa do
botafogo em contar grande pb watch ótimo
o caso também foi qualquer que agora é
exatamente uma vitamina
eu assisti a algumas coisas vocês
assisti lá pensei eu assisti algumas
coisas do aflitos e outras coisa eu acho
muito nojento e racista não acho muito
sem noção
eu sei lá sim mais gostava era sua
esposa
eu conheço o júnior o jô na selva que é
nem não o povo se for ano
minha gente como maior a ilha é muito
mágico lo do do landal time mandar o
link do youtube pra mim e pra bola do do
facebook o game roda eijk o ensino nos
mandar o time tem um bate-papo uma
entrada de webó pronto manda pra mim
aqui no bate papo a gente não fala
comigo pensei se bush não conquistam
velho só não gostou e youtube
e aqui como cantora no facebook não
mandei joão naia é esse aí droga
ricardo araújo vai repetindo que camila
eu te amo o isso fale mais você tá ela
não é de hoje é de fortaleza contra o
avaí no olímpico faz um ano que eu
conheci você não vê
ainda é o que tem é não acreditar mas é
porque é tudo 100 meu
é o que ele não deveria ter também mas
foi maior e melhor ainda você já é maior
você pode andar pelos danos sozinho não
posso sair amanhã
adoro ficar só vai saber na pergunta da
galera aí que a galera gosta de se
comunicar com a gente então a roupa pra
porangatu goiás fechou o dólar já foi às
clique aqui
minha irmã a aula apaixonou indo fotos
vem e eu e você arrasa corações mole vai
cantar o galo volta ou não todo mundo
falou toda prova bora bora busca e preta
só ó prova da taça regional né
não vai me parar foi minha mãe quem me
criei foi minha avó ela ficava só em
casa ia pra feira trabalhar deixar o pc
desligado profissional e tráfego tinha
se escondido da minha vó minha filha que
se libertar não fez que é melhor
a mandatária no google pede que as
nações decaiu é fábio para o memorando é
postar de manhã serão que ela sabe só
começava a tirar foto vida louca já
estava no photoshop quando fez seu pai
está a fim de semana fazem o público a
ir à escola o resultado pagar e bem na
hora minha voz foi me ligar a tanta
gente chorando que deu pra escutar
alô alô zorra
o bóton nota o hubble lascado nosso
reclama do motor quebrou josé riva rojer
provar quem é e que foi caminhões
quero botar ai quero matar meu chefe que
fez é tua boca com saber ou me mordendo
vai ficar querendo vai ficar querendo
não quero aids no meu corpo se mexer no
assim tá querendo ficar querendo que é
teu cabelo pichai mt trazendo aceitar
querendo a fim que a canon lembrada
carnaval que passou das quartas dengue
que você nem me procurou agora seco
história de querer votar pacífico dessa
renda que pra lá pode ficar para quem
não pode chamar o socorro pode querer
ficar quero e não é isso é isso r
domador que pra você ver o que a gente
tem
oi aqui vocês conhecem já parte porque
nunca vi jogar nem na feira
eu quero perguntar aqui ajoelhou selva
um jornal eu sei que estava com uma
condição de filho que você que já
conhece esse pessoal este meio é muito
tempo quer saber vai ter disse encontro
este ano o campus party o disse o
desencontro em fortaleza campo pela
comdec conde encontra em fortaleza já
cada estado brasileiro e recife esse ano
vai ter o que não só com os pais copo
farenight onde eu vou dessa vez eu pouco
eu vou lembrar o ídolo mandou nem que eu
tenho que dizer à mãe que vai trabalhar
só eu eu acho que o desencontro só rola
com 23 21 mas tem um pessoal que coisa
que vai pra ver
é mas sei lá eu acho que a gente deveria
ir pra ver a gente convidar gente vai
ser convidado por esse ano
esse ano é do nordeste [ __ ] eu eu faço
trabalho com o youtube eu faço as
pessoas no youtube assim como vocês
também faz o trabalho de vocês eu acho
que deveria ser mais reconhecido ontem
muito canal e que o minecraft inicial
sempre estão sempre sendo visto com
madonna para fazer as pessoas rir então
a gente merece negócio tem mas eu queria
muito justamente é isso que em que
gabriel está tentando fazer aí com a
gente é l interesse porque a galera lá é
unida no youtube é mesmo fugir ou n para
fazer isso
o chá é muito nivelado
a gente trabalha sério e aí matheus usa
aquele abraço meu filho
um abraço e vai colar de detalhes é a
jessica meta pergunta nunes 1 porque zé
roberto gilberto porque um dos meus
vídeos mais acessados meus mais
engraçada pra falar a verdade foi o meu
filho mas
o iphone é é um conto uma história em
que eu faço piadas com o meu nome e aí o
sr roberto pessoa até hoje me chamam de
romã então se você não assistiu vai no
youtube pesquisa oi meu nome é joão em
que seu nome é chão deu mais um ano
meu nome é joão eu vi eu compartilhei
1.211 mandar um beijo para pablo vaz que
o que ele está pedindo
eu quero quero mandar um beijo da school
que ele me pediu a mão da menina são
bobina
um homem ficou bem linda aquela criatura
espanhol que fica cantando bruno
cavalcante que jogou água e tomar ela a
situação nem vamos ver aí a pergunta da
galera a galera gosta de se comunicar
com a gente vão sair é porque fica muito
ruim todo mundo ficar atento às minhas
perguntas não só todas as perguntas pra
gente aí
as maiores são joão na prática ele era
ataque quatro canais do youtube norte da
china no ea gente vai responder às
perguntas aí começa a encarar o povo deu
oito bando quando é que eu vou fazer
olha o fato eu vou um beijo e batom mais
que fala ou do canal falar agora pode
ver a escola conta com um gol de choi
igual
o canal é bom pra caramba 8 mil é um
jovem fala golo e acessar york ae
ei também na fala um negócio aqui um
negócio muito sério agora todo muita
polêmica polêmico
você ainda é virgem camila claro que eu
sou louca porque não só a diva tem que
lá então virgindade porque tá tão
sucesso olvidado mas ela não virgem
insígnia é novo ou a oi venceu este
domingo a história do homem que foi lá a
virgindade ainda botou exigência nenhuma
mas ele queria o meu menino né
ae o homem com roupa com ele
eu vim aqui que é só coisa só por dois
mil dólares para boi dormir ganhar e já
saiu foi nulo pt gente é pego nas
esquinas trabalhar de graça o carro mas
na verdade não é só ficar na chave que é
estuprador programa porque menina lá
crise se eu amo tá mais pra ela a idéia
parece não sabiam nem genô ainda não deu
não ela vai dar ainda fazer um
documentário no caso uma agenda tão oxi
é o povo está incentivando como aquele
novo a virgindade me achei vamos
melhorar daqui a pouco a vir a controlar
a virgindade da gostar da urina pessoa
para sófia a pessoa não tá dando pra
qualquer pessoa
hoje acho que vou lê-lo a minha rocha já
tem dois filhos vai lá só quando o
motivo porque eu acho que eu tiro quando
nessa merda cada um e não vem aí uma
menina neve a história não queria não
queria dar com o prefeito dela
aí ela foi com meyong iria para comer o
tipo dela
aí quando ele foi com o meu tipo dela
ela fez colocou esse o produtor don hahn
o fmi como l
ela a menina mora comigo falou comigo
mas não tinha que namora maior que ainda
dá pra ele
pinto em que o king melo a ii
aí foi com ele assim que funcionava
quando entrar no buraco de trás
ae não foi foi tão grande a dor que ela
cantou em cima do palco nome e até hoje
a filha dela cagona meu pai veja veja
minha situação pois não quer ter carga
nas calças quer estar no colégio não ela
gostou do país chamado de carbono na
frente dela me serve como consolo da
história
moral da história não cabe no paley tá
vendo claro que não vai ficar no pau
a gente fala pra todo mundo misericórdia
vê constrangimento da menina
não vejo constrangimento da menina a
pessoa vai fazer um sexo pela primeira
vez quando vai fazer um sexo não aguenta
a pressão e ainda no palm série com
minha mãe é que o novo maiores de 18
anos e maiores de 18 anos
galera esse negócio não é enquanto
quantas pessoas bem no momento
joguei de 323 tá faltando gordinho para
chegar aqui é a primeira vez que eu faça
um bom mandato no youtube
eu nunca parei para pensar na vida eu
sou um combate que o tempo faz que eu
faço no caso o que as pessoas fazem
aparecem as exibições
gostei e eu não consegui fazer isso olha
aí o thalisson coxa ele disse que gravou
a gente cantando na luva ou reprovado
depois falou comigo foi assim em le
monde pra gente manda perguntar pra
galera ao jornal lê menina camila agora
tem que fazer um vídeo aceita se essa
internet não voltar a operar com o
caçula avaí
o boi tem que fazer uma música é uma
paródia de si alec leque
hoje não vou fazer vou fazer e até já
tomou a menina até mostrar gente
gente eu decretei eu tive um plágio de
idéia
sem saber eu ia fazer um vídeo de si é
leclerc a 1 para o águia e quando fui
ver já tinham feito idêntico ao que fui
eu
o athletic telec lep net é filé volta
vai ser um tapa na cara de vovó lá no
alto do eucalipto amarela como gravar
hoje vai fechar seu macho pra ir pra são
paulo que não vai pode ver quem vai vai
que vai fazer o que a procura parceria
cara tem meia hora está o nih procurar o
queijo não deixa pensar o que vocês já
pensaram em vamos pensar em fazer um
canal para gabriel
motivei com isso eu camila e joão botar
a não separar do canal da gente botar um
vídeo cada cada pessoa fica responsável
por lia cinco dias na semana nessa
pessoa a cada segundo cada dia da semana
tem um vídeo que alguma pessoa no no
canal
eu pensei muito nisso só que eu o que eu
pensei por que a gente fosse chegar um
dia na semana
a gente tem que entender que a gente não
é mais menino pequeno que faz o
desempenho é de que alguns coisa pra
fazer fora da internet deu então pode
haver um dia que a gente não vai
conseguir com a av
então pra não ter essa compromisso de
colocar vídeo e tal eu achei melhor não
falar isso pra você e eu já tinha tido
essa idéia mas o mesmo assim sem dia
marcado mas é uma idéia boa na fila do
problema e também porque é um problema
da monetização aí meu vídeo dá mais do
que eu tenho aí eu vou querer ganhar
mais do que tenho como é isso aí não
fica pra quem não sabe o que é esse
quando a mulher se manifestação
então a gente criar uma conta é vamos
deixar essa conversa é essa aqui com o
pessoal do youtube vamos atenção pra
eles e pra gente começa a gente aqui que
sabem nada
assim o jádel já deu muito tempo essa
nível que segue até amanhã acaba já o
meia noite galera que me conhece aí pode
adicionar unb eo ritmo
ai galera que conhece eles podem
adicionar também no facebook junho a
selva já deve conhecer o elevador fazer
pregação
eu não sou um gol em soluções no mercado
nacional que se inscrevam neste canal
quem gostei nessa livre é ótimo deixar
gravado aqui e dá um sinal baixo pois
bem mas vamos gente vamos melhorá então
adiciona aí o juno selva
adicione a isso o paddock entrar no
canal do rio dilma ainda no canal do
ruim cíclica lá e gostei no primeiro
vídeo dele agora o mais novo que é o da
infância entra no meio quem ela é e
gostei no novo agora que é como é
é o do fedorento pública no mundo ou o
tgv e da costa e nuno como é ou não
daquele rali sheik
ae a tese levava embora a maioria é o de
léo muito mas adiciona todo mundo no
facebook o meu é júnior selva muito
fácil e acha é o prometo e na próxima
livre a gente vai tentar fazer alguma
coisa mais legal mas elaborar a você
agora em colocar os dados colhidos na
hora gostei muito de última hora chamei
o pessoal ainda bem que todo mundo vê na
imagem se não viesse a ganhar aquela
falha a gente todo mundo entre uma vez
dá pra entrar todo mundo vamos tentar
que vão a gente combina outro melhor
então muito obrigado por você tem
assistido obrigado é ex n obrigado a lei
obrigado galera agradeço de coração todo
mundo aí e até a próxima vai vir com
essa galera retada do novo méxico
é isso aí olha e ainda som ver quantas
pessoas teve vem quando as pessoas têm
agora um exemplo se alguém quer que a
gente vá quem quer
acho que a galera negócio é rápido não
cabe a gente é caríssima compartilhou lá
o live da gente
quem cá que não disputaria compartilhou
a live da gente
quem quiser falar no caso da bandeira
uma outra pessoa por causa da portaria
pode curtir a apresentação só sei não
ficarmos nas costas
chan pode aí galera showzinho aí fica
aquela galera muito vácuo e e caí não é
somente a transmissão a gente vai
continuar conversando aqui falei pessoal
ou mais